let me test you on this I think did you
ever cheat on me and if you did why I've
had some pretty solid opportunities - ok
- when did you know it was over when you
hit me in the rib which are you that was
- honey go like we didn't have a healthy
relationship let's just say that I don't
know all the circumstances of this
relationship but I love how she you know
just like it's such a societal fact that
women can openly say that they put their
hands on the other person and everyone
just brushes it off
yeah countability what's that
accountability non what yeah
accountability what's that make sure you
guys smash that like button comic help
us out with that algorithm business and
yeah let's get it but you took a
high-heeled which honestly could
definitely be extremely dangerous and
you put in his rib okay but just judging
by her disposition she doesn't seem very
remorseful you know I mean listen we
don't know maybe he also plays hands on
her whatever you know oh she would have
said that brough no we don't know we
don't know bro we don't know knock it
off
am i a better lover than who you're
currently with I'm not clear if anybody
and my god yes
no her name boyfriend looks awesome
so he's pretty yeah I wouldn't call it
cheating was it a touch she's bothered
by yeah you got a whole new boyfriend in
our world - got a whole new boyfriend
took her credit though I could see how
if you've used someone highly and you
thought you guys ended on specific terms
I might be able to hurt to know that
they did she we were in the same bed
together how do you mean much I relate
to dude she was like you want to touch
my titty I was I got touch her titty I
was like what a nice titty and I was
like now that's it go to sleep
would you consider that cheating yes you
know what cheating is Bailey is going
it's just passing the the agreements
that you guy that fair it's just what it
is
it's just that what that is so if but I
know too many people who stipulate at
the star that can relationship
you can't touch anyone else yeah there
was someone I was seeing I'm like right
impressed had it never feel like I had
it know she felt like she had it because
said she she's not like hurt was her
egos a little bruised was a question did
did you ever cheat on me no and he's
kind of thinking about it huh and she's
like you cheated on me I'm impressed
that you had the balls who was the first
person you made out with after we broke
our price a our gym your chowder's for
that too childish
this is school take a shot
random girl named Kelsey in New Orleans
wanna know you could take a shot she's
gonna want to hear it because lalala
ticket take a look
laughs pick a side pick a song it's you
don't want to hear it I dare you to take
a body shot off me or take two to get
out of it he's gonna do it I don't think
he's gonna want to do it I don't know
he's for he strikes me as a white knight
you have a boyfriend I respect this
gentleman cuz I do remember earlier when
he was just like your boyfriend's is so
of million courses that would be wavered
back now let me drink this alcohol you
know what a body sorry I have seen that
but I've seen only between girls not on
the belly ones not the real body shots
there's two ways of doing a body shots
anything in the belly button which is
disgusting got damn Skippy ruined body
shots welcome to my room
here's my poster of the Osmonds and over
here is my belly button lint collection
cuz people don't clean their belly
button it's not even that even if you
clean it you in a club you sweat and
where you think all the sweat goes wet
weight on that night when it's hot it's
like in the worst places that I've seen
people do body shots at the hottest
place ever Florida I think you should be
reading it's not the Sunshine State
it's the body shot state of the Miami
people do body shots the whole night and
then you got like some bucha are you do
you think I'll be a good wife yeah
Wow he regrets what she did I don't know
what the hell what the hell happy to
hear my breath yeah but you regret
that's a whole lot of regret I wanted
you to be my wife
regrets regrets yeah not such a good
show would you go out with me again
he's taking me to dinner she's thanking
me to dinner you're taking me to dinner
we had a really toxic relationship but I
put my heel on his rib now let's go buy
me some ribs is that large football gear
get all the why would you go out with me
and you know the answer
there you go I don't know what it is
with the regret so how he thought but he
knows it clap your hands if you [ __ ]
up in you know with clap your hands if
you could do it over again what would
you change definitely not be so violent
and aggressive towards you then I like
yeah I was right to dislike her I mean
maybe she's changed it good for her but
yeah when when when women are violent I
feel the same way that even if a man's
violent yeah that's a Paris after just
people who are vying with their partners
to me there's something in here it's not
gonna be as devastating I understand
that so it still to me it's just issues
that's what I hear
do you still love me yeah yeah
of course
when you move into the future and you're
you're no longer connected I just don't
[Music]
like unresolved it does feel like we
shouldn't be watching like it's all fun
and games until they cry and do you see
that there's some underneath all these
shoes and you're like right here like
that the only reason why I feel a little
bit weird is because it seems like
there's a lot of conversations do I have
and I don't think having it on a public
platform with millions of people
commenting and putting their input is
like the most conducive yeah I think
it's not somewhat I'm disgusted so much
as it's like I what the both I mean I
feel like yeah I should be talking I get
its entertainment and so for all of us
watching at home we get to be like oh
but it does feel like they would have
much better odds of maintaining and
keeping that relationship strong if it
was kept in private yeah you know it's
interesting cuz someone left a comment
they said average seems like you're
really uncomfortable of people showing
emotions I have no problem with people
being vulnerable in fact when people
involved well in front of me it doesn't
bother me that being said sometimes I do
feel like some of this stuff is better
private both for like the success of the
relationship and for the person who's
being vulnerable there's something
really weird when you're being
vulnerable and you're having random
YouTube comments comment on it it is
very it does feel very perverse I don't
know why but it's just like the idea
like you view me like crying and so I
was like I find it so sexy when you cry
and just reading that is just it makes
you feel like someone stared at you
naked and they're like I want to eat you
like shrimp it's just I don't know it
makes me uneasy when I know that
interactions gonna happen but I have no
problem with you before but I think it's
healthy that he's able to talk about his
emotion I wish you success and luck
and health and all the best
[Music]
apparently he did the video and then it
caused repercussions for him in his real
life in his life or her life who knows
but maybe you have course of course
yeah but that's why I said that's why I
said you should never have these
conversations yeah yeah but of course it
would cause like repercussion in her
life of course not yeah I get him I was
like maybe even him maybe there's some
girl who will see was here yeah I'm not
gonna cry Blaine well that day actually
we were supposed to go on a date and
then someone in house contacted me was a
good friend of mine and told me that it
was happening and it just so happened
that that exact day we were going on a
date and didn't know we were gonna do
well we just planned a day to hang out
it was just a casual hanging out with an
old friend so I asked her she was into
doing it and she said yes my name is
Sophia and I'm Tony we who used to date
is dating the right word so we lived
together for four years
but you know what all those terms are
pretty unclear undefined I'm mad at you
yeah so I can I'm gonna say what he felt
that way about that word and I can
understand what she may have used the
wrong word yes okay here's how I define
the day if you I know people always ask
it's like to me a date is when you hang
out with somebody that you potentially
have romantic interested that's it
doesn't mean that those interests are
gonna be actualized doesn't mean that
you owe me anything
but that's how I view it now flip side
we've been telling me that they don't
like the idea of the date and I can
understand why they wouldn't like the
idea of the word date because they feel
like then they're obligated to do
something during the Hangout mm-hmm so
they'd like to set the men's
expectations lower low so that if they
don't want anything involved they won't
have to feel better than angry so that's
how I understand it that being said I
don't think hanging out to me just seems
bad because then I'm like that's what I
do with a friend
and I'm not going into this with the
same intention
so it seems disingenuous to cry well I
understand why people say if you could
do it over again what would you change I
think it ended when it needed to I would
put in more time that would have been a
quote I don't think we will because when
we broke up we had to acknowledge some
of the things that weren't working when
did you know it was over when your
friends became more important than me I
didn't feel like my friends became a
priority it was just like I knew what
kind of support I needed and I wasn't
getting it from you we needed to not be
together in that way but it was
important for us to keep what we thought
was valuable which was our friendship do
you still love me of course that
question could have been a problem
especially for hanging out together
because they were going on deep and had
nothing to do with this video I know
that could be a problem
you pulled one and one together it's
like yeah yeah it depends on the people
involved Oh her again the one that's you
love you know what I would think I would
think that if we ran into a rough patch
and you were feeling some type of weird
way about our relationship that would be
the first person asleep and then and
then it would run through my mind that I
would be like I should have known it you
don't agree that's what I would think
because I'm a pretty trusting and open
person but I can see that scenario
happening when you really love someone
you want them to be happy
and you let them go are you happy with
our curve
relationship are you happy in some ways
yeah good then yes I was yeah no no I'm
not dude you said you didn't date nobody
am i a better lover than who you're
currently with
fanni but there you go that's where it's
the problem for you cuz I remember a
video he liked am I better than the
person that you're dating or nothing
like I'm not dating anyone and yes
brother
and then you're dating someone bro of
course listen to wrap this up it came
back to what I said earlier say certain
things need to be kept offline now
obviously there's probably a larger
problem with him not acknowledging the
person he's currently dating when
spending time with his ex I would feel
some type of way if someone did that if
we were dating but well yeah I did think
it was great that they were able to have
a better say you don't you gonna deny
the relationship he denied the
relationship he had with the girl then
went on to say that his ex I love you
and I I was I had a lot of empathy for
this but not like brother
yeah busy leave your comments below we
want to hear your thoughts about this
video
[Music]
we dated and then we live together and
we were in a very serious relationship
wait I mean that was like five years ago
yeah so a Lebec yeah I had to pick us a
fax that was interesting she skipped
over all of us for recent exes to go for
the one that's like not gonna make her
look terrible I'm not crazy
yeah of course no matter if the only
control that you have they're gonna have
the editing let me choose the ex yeah
okay most people at least one exile just
like what did your friends and parents
think of me everyone loves you but
everyone hates you as my boyfriend
oh he's supposed to drink or answer he's
like everyone loves you but they hate
you as my boyfriend that's interesting
because of what she told them cuz
normally well no then they would hate
him do you do what I'm saying mmm
and normally if you're a good
significant other people like you're so
good for my daughter because they like
if they like you they want you to stay
with the personal relations right mmm my
mom loved you really yes I stopped
calling on new years because I didn't
want it to be weird my cousin that was
weird right I'm happy I don't know that
was serious or not what happened my
cousin oh and he's like no if you
stopped being a girl would you still be
in contact with their fans well she is
you're okay
what circumstance would you stay in
contact with the person's family how we
broke up okay make sense the only reason
I was still talk to the family was that
like like that would be if would have a
kid mm-hmm
I'm not talking about like seeing the
family when the kid comes by anything
but like keeping regular contact I'd
have a key okay interesting leave us a
comment below what do you guys stay in
contact with somebody family if you stop
seeing them and if yes or no under what
circumstance but it is dependent they
want to see my favorite they depend of a
lot of factors